make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting back into dark
nights not dark nights metal the Batman
who last and again like in the last
video that we had we were talking about
the nature of like the last laugh
protocol right and how Batman had
activated it now for those who guys who
were catching up the last laugh protocol
was a protocol designed by Batman for
the purpose of like cutting off Gotham
from the rest of essentially like the
world right like just totally isolating
the city in its entirety in case
something happened like the Joker
decided to release Joker toxin into the
water system or something like that
Batman could activate it and keep the
toxin from spreading throughout like the
rest of the country the surrounding
cities different things like that and so
because of the because of the whole
situation the way it's unfolding when
Batman activated this didn't suddenly
turn into okay Batman's basically
sighted against everyone and that was
kind of where we were left right like we
were left with this idea the Batman has
cited against like like everybody and he
had basically joined the Batman who
laughs and that's kind of the funny
thing because where you have Alfred in
his ear telling him hey look like your
toxicity levels are getting super-high
if you keep doing what you're doing like
if you go into any kind of situation
that heightens your adrenaline then
you're gonna switch over to the Batman
who laughs right because your cells are
almost completely irradiated with his
whole formula and you're gonna end up
turning into him and that's when Batman
kind of chimes in and says no no I
didn't activate this because I'm
becoming the Batman who last I activated
this because it's the only chance we
have and that's kind of the cool thing
because then you have the son of
Commissioner Gordon who comes in and
says yeah it basically buys us time now
remember the son of James Gordon yo
James Gordon jr. is basically crazy at
like a serial killer right and so
bringing him in here this kind of [ __ ]
kind of Batman's way of being able to
see into the eye of a crazy person but
the issue with this is that as Batman
has slowly started to become the Batman
who laughs what is done is this kind of
altered his perspective to where he can
sort of see directly into his mind and
not not literally but insofar as
functioning akin to him and how he
thinks and that's what he says
I pretty much am him like I almost am a
Batman who lost I know his one real
weakness I know where all of this is
leading to and so what this does is it
allows them to essentially set a trap
taking over the entirety of the power
grid and allowing it only to really be
controlled from from from the Batcave
what it means is like they're the only
person that can do anything with it now
of course Batman also acknowledges that
the grim Knight right like the Punisher
bat Batman from an alternate reality can
basically like hack into the power grid
and do whatever it is they need to do
but it'll take time to achieve that
which buys them time they didn't have
before and so again it's kind of a cool
little
because we basically switch over to like
an alternate reality when you end up
having like some version of Bruce Wayne
that basically bought everything right
like literally bought everything in
Gotham City
like everything runs under under like
the funding of Bruce Wayne it's like he
privates privatized the entire like all
the city services the police the fire
department the whole nine yards and
where somebody could do that and use it
for nefarious ends he actually did it
for it for basically a benefit
essentially saying like so long as my
company makes money you guys will be
funded you're no longer relying on
taxpayer dollars which means taxpayer
dollars can actually be used towards
things that can truly benefit society as
opposed to just you know funding cops
and all that kind of good stuff and so
as a result of that we end up having
this alternate reality version of Batman
that basically vanishes right it's also
the reality version of Bruce that just
kind of gets whisked away when the
Batman who laughs goes to take him out
and of course that's when he really kind
of chimes in and says that is Bruce
Wayne who did it now following this is a
really really cool exchange that takes
place between Commissioner James Gordon
and his son James Gordon jr. and jr.
tries to like talk to his father right
and almost seems to try to make the hill
pitch this case that when it's all said
and done and they're in you know in the
end the smoke clears that like they
should consider setting him free
and the response of Jim is no because I
just don't trust you because I think
you're still crazy I think you're still
insane like the like all indications
here are that he still believes his son
is a villain that he'll try to get him
the help he needs he'll try to make sure
they're treated fairly but it's like he
doesn't view him as his own son he views
him as like a criminal he happens to be
working with that seems to share the
same name as him and it's one heck of a
way for a father to view a son in a way
that's almost kind of like hopeless it's
pretty dark and is pretty twisted and is
pretty grim but from there again we kind
of switch back over to Batman in this
fight he has with the Batman who laughs
and this is kind of a cool moment
because when when Bruce Wayne shows up
here of course the Batman who lost is
hot on his trail and basically says hey
like like you know Bruce is like I knew
you're gonna be here and Batman who
laughs is like yeah I knew you're gonna
be here too and you're slowly but you
know turning into me and it's almost
kind of like mind games and that's one
of the things you don't really see when
it comes to Bruce Wayne when it comes to
him like like trying with people it's
usually based on fear right it's usually
based on the idea of like I'm going to
use fear to try to overcome you so it is
mind games insofar as he plays on
people's psychological perspective of
like fear and all that kind of good
stuff but with a Batman who laughs he's
really more just maniacal and so seeing
him play mind games with Bruce Wayne
like yes man you're becoming me like
you're slowly turning into me there's
nothing you can do about it you know
like you believe
you have this great big huge grandiose
plant set but I promise you this was all
according to me like everything that's
happening here is is happening because I
wanted it to it's kind of a cool little
exchange now we know the Batman who last
really loves doing that I mean we seen
from the stories you know the way the
stories have been written that he loves
focusing and kind of messing with
people's individual minds he talked
about things like killing the entire bat
family you know when you had like Bruce
Wayne who was kind of like you know I
guess when he was turning into the
Batman who last when the toxin first
began to infect him it was kind of like
okay I can maintain my sanity I can
maintain Who I am and and all it takes
is the smallest push the smallest nudge
over the edge kind of a homage to to you
The Killing Joke with all it takes is
one bad day and so what he ends up
saying here is that like hey when it
came to the to the bat family in my
universe where I come from I wanted to
make sure they were aware of what was
going on so I invited them over for tea
and setting the tea out was enough of an
adrenaline push to push me over the edge
and when they showed up I killed them
all it's just it's it's little things
like that right like just kind of like
this is how twisted and screwed up
you're gonna become and there's nothing
you can do about it there's nothing you
can do to stop it and so following that
we yell again kind of switching back
over to Commissioner Gordon and James
Gordon jr. we get this really cool
segment right where like they introduced
the bat armory and then of course when
they come out and the grim Knights
they're kind of going crazy and doing
all kinds of bonkers stuff they end up
busting out with like these Batman
Beyond costumes and it looks so amazing
like it's it's it's pretty badass I'm
almost inclined to call this like the
Batman who lasts beyond right like
because it's it's so cool to see like
these little these little homage is
right because when you're Scott Snyder
and you're sitting down and you're
writing a story about the Batman mythos
it's huge in its expansive right and
Batman Beyond is is a beloved show for a
lot of people right they grew up
watching that show they thought it was
amazing I'm curious like like how much
do you guys love Batman Beyond I'm kind
of curious about that because it was
after my time but a lot of you guys
really seemed to enjoy it I mean it's
pretty cool play this is a pretty cool
concept but again like they're showing
up here with the intention of being able
to take out the grim Knight they
actually get dealt with pretty quickly
right in and assume that they're kind of
taken out pretty fast but it is a cool
moment because what you have are these
kind of battles going on in two fronts
right you've got you've got the grim
Knight versus Jim Gordon because
remember in the grim Knights reality he
was defeated by Commissioner Gordon so
he kind of holds a grudge against
seemingly
anybody who's Commissioner Gordon in any
universe regardless of where it is and
then of course you've got Batman and
you've got the Batman who lasts but
between the grim nine and Jim Gordon
what he does is kind of hit on him and
say hey man like
not as great as you think you are in my
reality you gave up on your son but you
look at your son as a person who
couldn't be fixed who was incorrigible
essentially everything that you're
saying now about your son is all the
things that you said in my universe so
yeah you're as crappy as I think you are
you're nowhere near as great as you
believe you are and it's kind of a cool
thing it's kind of a cool moment because
what it does is it puts it into
perspective that like Jim Gordon really
liked kind of you know
harkening back to the things he said to
his son is not that great of a human
being he just kind of gave up on his son
or just something that no person should
ever kneel no parent should ever give up
on their child as it was kind of like
what kind of a parent is he really
now again of course the fight between
Batman and the Batman whoo laughs I
think it's a lot more desperate because
in this fight what you have here is
essentially Batman not really fighting
the Batman who lasts so much is fighting
to become that version of himself right
I mean because it's the one thing he
seems to be the most terrified of
becoming some twisted version of himself
this bent by nothing but chaos and evil
and all it wants to do is just like
inflict as much damage death and
destruction as it can like Batman's
terrified of that that Joker takes hold
basically and like he's infected
forevermore and like having an earth
where there's two Batman who laughs
running around that would be bonkers
like I mean you're talking about
probably the death of the Justice League
you're talking about the deaths of most
of the superheroes because you have all
the ingenuity and all the intelligence
of Batman combined with all the insanity
and the chaotic nature of the Joker and
then you double that and then you said
it loose on the superhero community what
hope does anybody have right so like
Batman's not just fighting for himself
he's kind of fighting for the world in a
lot of different ways and that's really
when he kind of hits a day you know when
the Batman who laughs talks about a lack
of hope and he says you have no real
hope here and there's nothing you can
really do to win the responsive Bruce is
I have one hope like like I found a
universe where there is a version of
Bruce Wayne that is hopeful well there
is a version of Bruce Wayne that hasn't
given up yet that hasn't like gone down
this dark path that I've set myself on
and it's basically the child version of
himself from a different universe and of
course this version comes running in and
Bruce's like hey go with them go take
off to the Batcave it's designed to be
hopeful and that's kind of the crazy
thing because what this does is it seems
to hit the idea that Bruce Wayne expects
to die that bringing that version of
himself over into the universe will
basically lead to him dying where that
khana seems to be the case now again I
doubt that's exactly what will happen
but it's almost kind of like Bruce Wayne
is expecting that right because it's
like okay I'm probably gonna die in this
fight and if I do somebody else used to
carry on the the Batman mantle and
there's a version of myself out there I
want him
have the life that I never had for
myself right like almost kind of like a
parent of sorts and so it's cool to see
this this little a little bit of a
scenario play out and so again like I
get real with Commissioner Gordon and
with the grim night Commissioner
Gordon's basically toppled he's
essentially taken out it kind of goes
back and forth and back and forth and so
on this last little bit of the story
where things begin to kind of close out
the Batman who laughs ultimately gets
the upper hand and like going to attack
Bruce Wayne he manages to subdue him
grab the serum he has in his possession
and inject it into Bruce Wayne
essentially turning Bruce Wayne into the
Batman who lasts it's one of the coolest
things like it's one of the most awesome
things ever and I am hyped for this so
again a relatively short issue really
more action than anything else but it's
pretty solid
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here - comments explained to
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]